Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in the chapter of
vigilance, vigilance of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
watching, vigilance of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's listening to us,
vigilance of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
knowledge, having constant
knowledge and awareness
that Allah subhanaha
is above us watching us and observing.
we stopped at the narration of
and
we started the
summarized biography of basically
we're going to mention when we come
across a narrator a companion
we're going to try to keep it as
concise as possible so that we're able
to memorize it But we want it to also be
more than just a few footnotes.
Otherwise, we will start to confuse all
of these names. We haven't met these
people. We're trying to get to know them
as if we have met them. And so,
memorizing just random names without
anything
that differentiates them from one
another is very difficult. So, we want
them to be more than just names that
we've heard of before. We want to know
who these men were. We started with
Mujab.
What is Muabel's?
Abu what?
Huh?
Abu Abdman. Yes. Abu Abdman.
Can we think of anybody else who has
that same?
Okay. Well, me. Yeah. of the companions.
Very good.
Another one that we all know.
We just listened to his father's
narration a couple days ago.
Omar.
Okay. So there's threebas
all
is one of the ansar he's ansari
but what's unique about jabal is that he
actually became Muslim before hijra
before the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam arrived at medina as a matter
of fact, he was one of the
people that pledged allegiance to him
while he was still in Mecca and helped
to facilitate his hijra from Mecca to
Medina and he was one of the companions
to receive him. He was there in
is when the came for Hajj and they met
at an area called
and they pledged allegiance to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam there that
if he came or when he would come to
Medina that they would protect him and
so forth. And so the tribe leaders and
the Muslim
were there in Medina to pledge
their allegiance to him.
Now there are two
in this happened twice. You have the
major and minor
was at the second of those. He became
Muslim when he was 18 years old. Very
young man and
he as we mentioned before accepted
Islam and was preparing for the prophet
sallallah.aii's
arrival in Medina. Another very
important point about Muad is that he
was in the battle of Badr. And the
battle of Badr is the most significant
battle in all of the history of Islam.
And the people that were in the battle
of Badr, the companions that were at the
battle of Badr, 312
or 13 or 14 or 15, the scholars differ
on exact numbers.
All of them have been guaranteed
forgiveness by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
he looked at the people he looked upon
the members of the battle of Badr and he
said do as you will for I have forgiven
Now
all
of the unsaw are one of two tribes.
Do we know these two tribes?
What their the names of these two tribes
are?
Al
are more virtuous than Alaz
in a general sense.
And in the battle of Badr only
members of Al were at the battle of
Badr. Remember the battle of Badr was
voluntary. As a matter of fact, no one
had any idea that it was going to even
be a battle until they were already at
Badr and the armies were all but lining
up to face one another. So it was a
surprise to everyone including the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. And so it
was voluntary. It was considered a raid.
It was a caravan that they were going to
intercept. That's all it was supposed to
be. It turned into a battle and the
companions
stood firm. That's why there were so few
of them. That's why they were not armed
in the way that was armed. And so
is one of any companion who is from the
and was in the battle of Badr, we know
automatically he is from which tribe?
Als remember these two tribes because
these two tribes were at each other's
throats for generations before the
prophet arrived in Medina. sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. They were in constant
competition with with each other and
they were in constant repraisals
with one another,
taking casualties on both sides,
fighting at every opportunity that
presented itself with one another. And
so
is one of we said Muad became Muslim
when he was how old? 18. Okay, here's
another fact to help you remember.
He passed away
in the year 18.
Okay, so he became Muslim when he was
18. He passed away in the year 18 after
hijb
was sent by the prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam to Yemen.
He was sent to call the people of Yemen
to Islam but not all of Yemen. Yemen is
a very big place.
Yemen was divided and even till recent
times till the the the days of the
collapse of the Soviet Union.
So in the 80s late 80s
Yemen was always divided into two sides.
the north and the south.
And
was sent to the region of
the region of
he was to preside over that region. The
other region Abu Mus Ashi ali a means
that he's Yemen. Ashi the name Ashari
means Yemen from Yemen. It's a tribe
from Yemen.
Okay. He was sent to preside over the
other half. Mu Jabel was sent in the
year 10 after Hij just a few months
before the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
passed away.
Now
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam walked Muad
out to the outskirts of Medina
to walk him out for him to start his
journey. He you know he escorted him out
to an area that used to be called
Have we heard of? I think we heard of it
because of the song that people would
sing when they were kids.
You guys know what I'm talking about?
Okay. So,
you know, when you go to the airport,
they have departures or they call
what do they call it? Kiss kiss and
they call it kiss and farewell or
something. Whatever. with that. It's the
place where people would see the
departures of their loved ones. You
don't have to have a ticket to be in
that area, right? It's where everybody
says goodbye. And that's the point where
the travelers are distinguished from the
residents.
is an area on the outskirts of Medina
that is referred to as
the the area of
bidding farewell is because that was the
departures wing of Medina. When people
left Medina to go travel, usually people
would their loved ones, their family,
whatever would walk with them to
bid farewell to them and from there they
would leave.
And it said the prophet
when he arrived in Medina, he arrived
from
that's why it's in the the the poem. And
so
he walked
out to
one of the virtues of Muad is that Muad
was writing and the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam was holding the reigns
to his
deba as he was escorting it. And this
is considered to be a great honor. And
he was telling things like
this very narration, right? He is
telling him these pieces of advice.
Another piece of advice
the narration of Abbas. You're going to
arrive in in Yemen. There's going to be
a lot of people there from the people of
the book. So the first thing you need to
invite them to is the worship of Allah
alone without any partners. Many pieces
of advice that he gave him. You wanted
to say something
temple. -huh.
Well, you know, there you go. Proof that
I'm not perfect. Okay. So as he escorted
him,
one of the things that the prophet said
to
is
you might come back to Medina and not
find me here. You might come back and
not find me alive. Muad understood that
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam was
going to pass away. He understood that
he was going to pass away while Muad was
in Yemen and there was nothing he could
do about it.
And so this was a very difficult
time for Muad.
And as he understood
while he was in Yemen, the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam passed away a few
months later because
Hajj
was in which year? Which year?
The final
the ninth year after
is which month? The 12th month is the
last month of the ninth year.
An easy way to remember is when he stood
and gave the
ona
and recited.
He passed away 81 days later.
81 days later.
Okay, which is 18. Reversing the
numbers. I'm trying to help you learn
the little tricks to memorize these
things. 81 days later, this happened
between the 10th year after Hij
between that time of
and when the prophet passed away
sending Muad was somewhere in there,
somewhere in that time. And when he was
in Yemen, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam passed away. He remained there
through the of Abu Bakr
and then a portion of the of Omar and
then when Omar became the Khalifa he
sent for Muad to come back from Yemen.
He said that he needed in in Medina,
but
continued to beg
to let him leave Medina because he said
that
Medina was just not the same without the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam there and
it was too painful for him to be there
and he did not want to be in Medina
anymore. And so reluctantly
allowed Muad to go up to Hashem.
What is so amazing about this,
the curiosities of Allah's decree is
that was
the exact timing of that was just a
little bit after he went to Hashem and
he arrived there. the plague of Amos
broke out. There was a plague, the
bubanic plague at the time that swept
through Hashem and claimed many, many,
many casualties during the of Omar. And
Muad happened to be in Dimash in Syria
at the time. And he was one of the
claimed of the plague, which is a type
of shahada the prophet sallallah.aihi
wasallam mentioned. So Muad passed away
in the year what which year? Which year
after Hijra? 18 year the 18th year after
Hijra. So if we kind of do a
calculation, Muad was somewhere between
32 years old and 35 years old when he
passed away. 36 somewhere in that range.
very young. He's in in scholarship
years. 35 36 years old is an infant
still crawling at 35 years old.
Scholarship,
it's amazing because in most other
fields, maybe in all fields, the older a
person gets, the less useful they become
in that field, right? Except for Islamic
scholarship, it's exactly the opposite.
The older the person gets, as long as
they are not, you know, they do not
become scenile, the more knowledgeable
they become, the more
valuable they become, the older they
become. And so if you look at a scholar
that's 70 years old, 75 years old when
he was 30, 35 years old,
you cannot you cannot even compare the
two as long as he continued to study and
as long as he continued to practice his
craft and refine it and hone his craft.
who passed away in the year 18 after
hijra in the of an area a region it's
referred to as but it swept through hem
in a very general way claimed a lot
of casualties and one of them was
so he passed away where in Hashem he
became Muslim in
before hijra and he passed way ine.
So we will mention some of his
virtues tomorrow inshallah and from
there we can go into the the the sto
the biography of
tomorrow. one of the virtues of that
we mentioned is that he is the most
knowledgeable
of this with respect to what
take two more two more virtues.
Another statement that the prophet
sallallahi wasallam made is that
He said the scholars will be brought
together in their own group on the day
of judgment and muad will be ahead of
them
by a stones throw.
So we have all the scholars here and we
have mu ahead of them by a stones throw
in front of Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala on
the day of judgment those are how many
virtues we mentioned two three
do we have any other narrations there
are many narrations regarding why the
bjab
Another virtue of
is that the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam said to
him in a
he said
I love you
said
[Silence]
this dua that we know at the end of
salah.
This was taught to mu by the prophet Sam
and he said I love you. Said I love you
too. He said
at after each prayer say
at the end of each prayer meaning in
after before
you make this dua. So it becomes one of
the this narration is from the mu the
narration of Jabba and he has roughly
100 narrations in the books of hadith
100 which is a very modest number but
it's because he died so early on in
the of
I want you guys to memorize this stuff.
Learn it. I already know it. So, I'm I
don't want to be teaching my only
teaching myself here, right? So,
practice, review,
consult with each other. If you if you
don't remember something, ask each
other, right? Review with each other.
These are important things.